The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HARVEY: We have today some
distinguished visitors,
Tim Ray on piano and Eugene
Friesen on his cello.
And they along
with another person
named Greg Hopkins form a
trio called Tre Corda, named
for one of the
pedals on the piano.
Tim Ray will explain it.
And as you know, they are
giving a concert this evening.
So you will all be
coming to that concert,
and I'll give you as I have
before the concert points
to write your concert
reflections from.
I'll send that out
later this afternoon.
That's at Killian
tonight 8 o'clock.
So you'll see the full group.
But they're here this afternoon.
So please give them
a warm welcome.
FRIESEN: Thank you.
HARVEY: Thanks.
RAY: Thank you.
Thanks.
So we're really glad to
be here, and as Mark said,
we're playing the
concert tonight.
So of course that's
the first requirement
for passing the class is
that you have to come.
We always make that joke.
Nobody laughs.
HARVEY: It's not a joke.
RAY: It's not a joke.
Oh that's why they don't laugh.
OK.
Now I get it.
HARVEY: I'm very serious here.
RAY: OK yeah.
In just a little bit, we
want to get into playing
and of course get you guys
playing as well, hopefully.
Just a little bit about
what we do as a trio.
As Mark said, our trumpet
player Greg Hopkins
will join us tonight.
And then you'll see Greg next
week in the class as well.
We are a trio.
We've been together--
gosh, I guess
it's getting to be about 12
years now, the three of us.
And we do, it's an
unusual instrumentation.
I mean at least unusual in
terms of traditional jazz trios
because there's no base.
There's no drums.
It's also unusual in
a classical setting.
Usually a piano trio with
cello usually has a violin
not trumpet.
So we're a little bit of a
hybrid kind of formation.
And it's something I had
the idea to put together,
like I said, about 12 years ago.
And a lot of what we
do is we play music
that we compose,
Eugene and myself
and Greg all write
for this group.
We're all improvisers.
So of course improvisation plays
a large part in what we do.
But we also delve
into classical music.
We delve into jazz,
Brazilian stuff.
And that's all our
backgrounds as well.
I mean, myself, Eugene, Greg--
we're all classically trained.
Then we're also
jazz players and do
a lot of things outside
of this group as well.
So besides that,
Eugene and I actually
have to a duo that we do.
We're going to actually play
a couple of songs from our duo
repertoire because it's a
little hard to do the trio
stuff without the third person.
Although we might mess around
a little bit later with that,
get you guys involved.
But anything you want to say?
FRIESEN: Sure.
I mean Mark just told us
the first thing about what
you guys have been
studying so far.
And how many of you
would categorize yourself
as classically
trained musicians?
OK.
Well that was my
background as well.
I was interested in
pop music and rock
really when I was in college.
But I spent most of
my energy in really
practicing classical repertoire.
And it wasn't until I
got out a music school
that I started to get a little
bit more serious about doing
the kind of ear training that
you need for improvising.
And for me it's been
a lifelong process.
I feel like I'm still
learning a lot about that
and learning to recognize chords
and to learn how to contribute
to a harmonic environment
just by listening
and by pitching in.
And but I've also had a
chance to do a lot of work
with classically
trained musicians who
have never tried before.
Kids of all ages, beginners,
middle school, high school
kids, and even
professionals who are really
very afraid to improvise.
In fact, last year
I had a chance
to do a presentation at the
American String Teachers
Association on improvising.
And I started this
presentation by asking,
what are some of the things
that keep us classically trained
musicians from improvising?
And there were about 100
people are so in that room,
and everybody had
something to say.
I mean I didn't realize
this could easily
have been the topic of
that whole presentation.
People really inherit,
I think, in our training
a tremendous amount
of inhibitions.
Some of it is the
impossibly high standards
that we are kind of
imbued with as students.
Some of which, of
course, is really
good for motivating
our hard work.
But a lot of which
really makes us kind of
cower when we're in a situation
where we're encouraged
to be creative
and play something
that we haven't
really rehearsed.
And so that's been kind of
the impetus of my teaching.
And one thing
that's really helped
me is setting some guidelines
that were comfortable for me
as a classically trained player.
So one of the first ways
that I felt I could improvise
was no wrong notes, completely
open, free improv stuff.
And I understand you
guys get to do that
each week with Tom Hall, right?
Am I correct in assuming
that at some point
you do some improvising
where you're not worrying
about chords or scales
or things like that?
It's really most about
interaction, right?
And how it comes together
rhythmically maybe.
I mean do you work on the
rhythmic side of things
more that way, or is
it more intuitive kind
of communicating?
Could someone
answer that for me?
AUDIENCE: Different things, and
different exercises, I guess.
FRIESEN: So it's
different all the time,
different guidelines for your
improv that you're doing there.
Gotcha.
Well that was-- the free
improv part of things
and not worrying about notes is
a tremendous liberator for me
as a classically trained player.
And then the next thing
was playing diatonically.
Learning how to create something
that really had heart, that
had shape, that had
personal expression for me,
but that was kind
of limited in terms
of how it wandered
from key to key.
And maybe we could play "First
Ride" as an example of that.
RAY: Sure.
That's great.
FRIESEN: I don't know where
Tim wanted to go with this.
We're just kind of winging this.
But for me this piece
that we're about to play
was really one of
the first improvs
that I did that was a real
successful cello and piano
improv.
It happened to be recorded
in a great cathedral
in New York, Saint
John the Divine.
And it had such a kind
of formal quality.
It's something that I
wanted to play in concerts.
So we transcribed it.
We went by went back and
listened to the recording
and really transcribed it.
It's like when you have
an improv like this,
it's kind of like capturing
lightning in a bottle in a way.
And if you want to
duplicate it, you
can take some of the themes
and stuff as the starting
off points, but in
this case, it seemed
to work so well as kind of
a thought through thing,
that we play it
as close as we can
to the recording as possible.
Now the piano part is
pretty much Tim's invention.
What he had from
the transcription
were a few right hand
lines that Paul Halley,
the original
improviser, improvised.
But the cello part is
really-- it's written.
It's the same cello part
that I originally improvised.
So this is called "First Ride."
RAY: Ready?
FRIESEN: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
RAY: Thanks.
and the construction had
the third in that chord.
I don't know if you
caught that, whatever
that machine is out there.
RAY: So I'd love to get
some of your thoughts
and some of your questions.
But basically that whole
thing that you heard just now,
as Eugene said, was all
originally freely improvised,
but in a diatonic setting
meaning we really never
left the key of D major, right?
I mean basically.
I mean, you see I've got all
these pages of transcription,
but it's all-- we might
try little exercise where
we do that with some of you
where diatonic-- we're staying
in one key, but we're just
moving the chords around,
moving the roots of these
chords around, doing
some improvisations,
and then doing
figures, motives,
melodies based on that.
Were there any questions,
any observations,
commentary, criticism?
Yes,
HARVEY: Adrian.
RAY: Adrian.
Thank you.
ADRIAN: I was wondering I
guess whether like there
was some sort of
design framework
that had been pre-planned,
like even some chord
progressions that you guys do?
FRIESEN: Nothing.
ADRIAN: Everything was just--
FRIESEN: Yeah.
RAY: Thanks.
Cool, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
original theme actually
reminded me a lot
of Cannon in D.
RAY: Of Cannon in D?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
where you started.
[INAUDIBLE]
[PLAYING CELLO]
FRIESEN: Is the melody.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I don't if
it's just because of the title
or just because
it's [INAUDIBLE].
RAY: That might of had
something to do with it.
I mean, I'm sure you probably
know when you're improvising,
you know you're
all you're always
drawing from things
that you know.
Drawing from music that you've
heard, drawing of course,
from the people around you
who are improvising as well.
So there's certainly
plenty of times
when I'm improvising
and I'll play something
and I'll be like, Oh, I
think that was the theme
song to some TV show from
the '70s without really
intentionally.
I mean obviously jazz
players will intentionally
throw in little quotes
for humorous effect.
But oftentimes, they don't
come out intentionally.
They just come out.
And that's sometimes
the fun part of it.
FRIESEN: I've heard it said
that you are what you eat.
You know that expression?
Certainly true for
us improvisers.
What you know and what
you listen to really
plays a huge part
in what you access
when you're really
and truly improvising.
Although there's another
thing that I might mention
about this particular piece
is that at least for me, there
was something about the
acoustics of the cathedral that
really activated my
imagination in a different way
than it had ever been before.
The way that the cello
just rose up in the room
somehow shifted my focus
from me and from my technique
to the room.
I mean it was almost like there
was this other kind of presence
in there that I
was tapping into.
And it was an important
experience for me.
And oftentimes when I'm in
an improvisational situation,
I place myself back
in the cathedral
because I really
felt like that was
where my voice as an
improviser was born.
It was the first time I had
that experience of really being
the music and not being a cello
player or even being a person.
RAY: Any other
comments or questions?
CHRIS: Not really a
question, but after hearing
that you said that the
[INAUDIBLE] design [INAUDIBLE].
That was really
inspiring that you
managed to come up with
something so varied.
Because I am really interested
in things like that.
Because I really like the
idea of trying to improvise
like that.
Just a simple idea.
And I guess that's my
favorite way of improvising.
But I always find
a sense of struggle
to come up of with a whole
variety of interesting things
maybe just from that
simple beginning.
That's really, really
cool that that--
FRIESEN: Can you hear what
he's saying well enough?
Yeah.
I mean maybe one of the
things he's hinting at
is the power there
is in limitation.
That when you really
set boundaries
about what your language
is going to be sometimes
that can be really liberating.
And in my case, with my limited
improv skills at that time--
that was a 1986
when we did that.
I was really a pretty
new improviser then.
The fact that we were
in an environment
where I could use
my open strings,
my harmonics, you know, I knew
what key we were in, really
helped me so much.
There's something about that
that just calmed me down,
and I think that that calmness
and the incredible acoustics
of the place helped for
this kind of magical moment
to happen.
Because it's a special moment.
A piece like that
is something that
really captured our
attention in a special way.
And that's why we
want to transcribe it.
That doesn't happen
every time we sit down
to play something compelling.
But it is amazing
what can happen
with kind of a limited
palette of harmony,
I guess you could say.
How that can ignite this
kind of passion and feeling
of warmth and rapture.
And what are some
other adjectives
you would use for that music?
RAY: Cool.
FRIESEN: No they've got it.
Some more adjectives.
How would you describe it?
Does it sound like
church music or?
AUDIENCE: Just calm.
FRIESEN: Calm.
Maybe that's the
diatomic part of it.
It's very grounded in that way.
RAY: Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, I mean I think the other
thing that-- I'm sorry, Chris.
Thank you.
Chris, at least in
my mind was when
he was talking about sort
of how much can come out
of a very small amount
of starter material,
if you want to call it that.
I think part of that
is also as Eugene said.
It's sometimes having
the limitations of just,
we're going to play
in D major, let's see
what happens, can
trigger these things.
I think some of the other
thing too is sometimes
when you're doing essentially
what I would consider freely
improvising, you're
always trying
to-- you're always listening.
You're always trying to think in
a larger form, a larger format.
You know I mean all the music
that we love has sections.
All the great
Mozart sonatas they
have different sections
that are contrasting.
Same with a great jazz piece.
They have different sections--
contrasting sections,
loud parts, soft
parts, a section that
features a particular soloist,
a section the features
the ensemble.
You know, these are
all things we're
trying to recreate in maybe not
necessarily a conscious way,
although I mean, you could
be more conscious about it.
But even when you're
just freely improvising,
and again, you might be working
on these kinds of things
already.
You're always kind of
listening for-- your listening
as you're playing.
You're kind of thinking
like, OK maybe it's
time to come down and
do a quiet section.
Or maybe this is building
up to a big section.
Maybe this is the climax.
Was that the climax?
I don't know.
Let's see where it goes.
But you're always
kind of-- I don't
want to say that you're
always judging and evaluating,
but in a certain
way the feelings
that you develop when you play
a great piece of classical music
or a great jazz
piece, these feelings
you're trying to recreate in
a freely improvised setting.
And often times you
can go back and you
can look through
what you just did.
With my students--
Eugene and I both
teach at the Berklee College.
A lot of times with
my piano students,
when we work on
improvisation, I'm
telling them you have
to record yourself.
You have to turn on your
phone or whatever you've got,
something just really easy
that you carry around with you.
You record your improvisation,
record your group
improvisations.
And then listen back and
go, Yeah this is great.
I didn't like this so much.
You know because that's
the way you learn.
That's a great learning tool,
and I think sometimes it's
one of those obvious things
that people don't think to do.
When, like I said,
from my perspective,
it's a really great
way to develop
a sense of what you're doing.
So I'd like to
play one more tune.
And then we'll maybe open it
up a little bit for you guys.
I'm wondering if we should do
something like the big violins,
maybe?
FRIESEN: Like the
blues in E minor?
RAY: Yeah.
Do you want to?
FRIESEN: Yeah.
Have you guys worked on blues?
Yeah, I'm sure you have.
Well again, for me as a
classically trained player,
the blues were and are
really, really challenging.
I mean just keeping
the form together,
I really had to have
the paper in front of me
for a long, long time just
to keep the twelve bar
thing together.
So but eventually it
became internalized.
And here is a blues
that I came up with.
I remember watching the shock
and awe invasion of Baghdad.
I was just sitting in
front of this big screen
TV with my cello, and what
I found myself playing
was this one, Ray.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
RAY: Cool.
So, I have so much playing
that with you, Eugene.
That's a gas.
So obviously blues form, right?
Were you're able to
keep track of it?
Mostly you could, right?
I mean that's one of things,
like I said before, as a jazz
group we're unusual because
there's no bass and no drums.
But of course, when
again this is something
I preach to some
of my own students.
It's like we're kind of
always the bass player.
We're always the drummer.
Even if you're playing a flute,
you're still the drummer,
right?
And I think that's one
of the things-- this
is one of the kinds of
playing that we do as a trio
where we actually
use those skills.
We use those like, OK, let's--
we have this internal thing
going on, this internal
metronome going on.
We don't need the ride
cymbal necessarily
because we're
keeping it together.
And then of course we
because we like to have fun
will throw caution
to the wind and do
some crazy stuff for a while.
But still in the back
of our mind, of course,
we're listening, too.
We're keeping
track of that time.
Any questions about that?
Comments?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess, I was wondering just
how-- [INAUDIBLE] on the piano,
you were like playing really
quick fast notes like that
[INAUDIBLE] the
cello, you ended,
you know every
time you did this,
you both ended at the same time.
And is it just that
you've played together
long enough that you sort of--
FRIESEN: Actually I
think that the moments
you may be referring to are
the things about the blues
form, where we would come
to the end of a phrase.
And as Tim was hinting at,
or articulating before,
when you feel like something
needs to change-- you know some
of those double bars in
the music, in this case
the end of the 12 bar form,
where we are crescendo-ing,
crescendo-ing getting crazier
and crazier and crazier.
It just feels like, Oh wouldn't
that be a nice dramatic moment
to just jump off the
cliff back into the head
into that real,
real simple thing.
AUDIENCE: I think two of the
times it happened at the end
of the 12 bars, I think
one was just at the end
of a [INAUDIBLE]--
FRIESEN: And that's
just lucking out.
And I think that's
probably what keeps
all of us doing this is
just that lucking out
part of the thing, just
not really knowing what's
going to happen.
And you know, none of
us wants to rehearse
so much that you can
depend on those things.
I love the very
expression, there's
no substitute for a genuine
lack of preparation.
Have you ever heard
that one before?
Because sometimes
when you're really
on the front of
your chair, you know
you're really listening
in a way that is enhanced.
And I think that is the
thing that keeps us musicians
doing this is that incredibly
intense process of listening
and presence, which by the way
is transmitted to the audience.
And we get a lot of
energy from the audience.
You probably know this
already, the value
of doing this in front of people
is enhanced exponentially.
And the quality of being in the
audience when you're witnessing
something that is
happening in real time
is something tangible.
Not only that, but as scientific
research has pointed out,
our brain research,
listeners will
have a similar kind
of experience brain
experience as the performers.
So we really get
this vicarious kind
of thrill, this
kind of vicarious
high just from being in
the presence of something
incredible that's going on.
Which is why I'm quite sure
that live performance will never
die.
You know, once we get over this
infatuation with the screens,
I think people will
be back at concerts
and live events like that.
And certainly the thing that
keeps us musicians at it
because there again the
enhanced listening that we
can do in rehearsal is very
different than it feels
like from playing for you guys.
You know there's an
extra level of attention
that comes to it that is--
And sometimes it's just a tiny
little switch in your brain
that makes all the
difference in the world.
It's so amazing.
You probably know this from
the musical work you've done
or the writing you've done.
Sometimes you'll sit
down and you'll just,
your body will just type
something really cool.
And you didn't even mean to do
it, it just kind of happened.
You can't force
that kind of thing.
RAY: Absolutely.
FRIESEN: Well, where should
we go from here, Tim?
RAY: So I wanted to
do this actually.
I wanted to hand out--
because I know some of you
have to leave early.
So my thinking for this
course-- you know, it is school.
You do have to
have an assignment.
So I'm going to hand
out a tune, and I
want to get back
to the improvising
in a diatonic setting
that Eugene and I were
doing earlier.
And that's what
I want to do kind
of with some of the
rest of this class.
But for the
assignment, I actually
want you guys to
work on something
similar to what we
were just doing.
We have a song, I'll
pass it out now.
We have a song in our trio
repertoire called "Cargasian."
This is it.
FRIESEN: Oh, cool.
I love this.
RAY: And basically,
what I would like
for you to do with
this-- check that out.
This is actually written by our
trumpet player, Greg Hopkins.
So of course, this
is a concert page.
So I guess actually I think
our saxophone player is
the only guy who's
going to have to--
FRIESEN: Trumpet
RAY: --do some transposition.
But at any rate-- oboe, nice.
So basically, like
I said, we treat--
we'll play this
tonight in our concert,
so you'll get to here
us do it as a trio.
Basically as you can see,
there's just a melody line.
Did I give you one, Mark?
I'm sorry.
No, I did.
FRIESEN: I'll take one, too.
RAY: So there's a melody
line, which you can see.
And this is also a
12 bar blues form.
So there's like a number one,
number two, number three.
These are the
different sections.
Number three you don't
have to worry about.
The chord changes so much,
those are mostly just
for my benefit as a pianist.
When we play the melody,
we all play in unison.
In other words, like
I said, no chords.
It's all just playing
this melody in unison.
So of course, the first
part of your assignment
is to be able to play
the melody in time.
It's similar tempo
to what we just did.
[HUMMING]
Nice little medium
swing kind of groove.
You have to watch out.
At the end there's some
three four measures.
You do have to play the
And then you see at the end on
the bottom of the page, solo
over G minor blues.
Now I know you guys have done
some work with the blues.
These are very basic-- this
is sort of a basic Minor blues
form, 12 bars.
And basically, what I
would like for you to do
is to take some of the
motives from the melody.
And maybe Eugene
and I will play it
once real quickly just
so you can hear it.
Take some of the motives
from this melody.
There's a few key things.
I'm sure once you hear them,
you'll be able to identify them
or you can circle
them or whatever.
Work with some of these motives.
Come up with some blues
improvisational ideas.
And then what I'd like to
do when Greg and I come back
on Monday is we'll
do essentially
what Eugene and I were doing.
I'll have you team up
in maybe twos or threes
and do some improvisation
over the blues.
And again a good way to
practice that is sit down
with a metronome, right?
I mean obviously, sitting down
with your friends is a better
way to practice, but sitting
down with a metronome,
having the metronome go, just
practicing improvisation.
Like I say, we'll play
through some of these figures
and have you kind of
identify some of those
and maybe try to work those into
some of your improvisations.
Can we play this
real quick, Eugene?
FRIESEN: Let's find out.
RAY: I guess we'll find out.
FRIESEN: It's been a while.
RAY: So like I said, we
always play this just
in unison, the melody.
On the way out, you'll hear
tonight at the concert,
we try to do a sort of a
cannon with the melody.
But we won't try the cannon now.
FRIESEN: So for now
we're just going
to read through three sections?
RAY: We're just going
to read through them.
FRIESEN: Just to
give the sound of it.
RAY: A one, two three.
[PLAYING MUSIC]
RAY: Right, we're ending, yeah.
And then the nice
diminished chord.
That's what we always
teach you, right?
End on a diminished chord?
Good compositional.
FRIESEN: Isn't that
a great melody?
I mean, that's like just the
coolest, Buddhist design never.
RAY: It's like a haiku.
FRIESEN: All that
space around you.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
put in bar lines?
What's the point?
FRIESEN: I think the
point is that we always
are really aligned.
We feel the beat together.
And you have to, right?
To play that.
AUDIENCE: You have
to, but I don't
feel the bar lines at all.
FRIESEN: Don't you?
Well, great.
RAY: That's good.
We like that.
FRIESEN: As Tim
mentioned, we know
we often do this in
unison then we'll play it
as a round at a bar and two
beats, is that how we do it?
Or one beat?
RAY: We start off the
three of us on the way out.
We play it unison together.
Like I said, coming
tonight, you'll hear it.
Then we do the improvisation,
which is like-- Whoops,
I lost my microphone.
The improvisation,
which is all three
of us improvising
at the same time.
It's not really like a
typical, one person's
a soloist and another
person's an accompanist.
FRIESEN: It's really
efficient time wise.
RAY: It's true.
Makes for a nice
short presentation.
And then on the way out,
yeah as Eugene was saying,
we do a round.
We start off trumpet and then
one measure later is you.
FRIESEN: At the bar, right.
RAY: One bar.
And then that piano
comes in one bar later.
So you get sort of
this round effect.
And then when we
get to section two,
we condense it to two beats.
And then when we get
to section three,
we condense it to one beat.
So we're only separated
by one beat apiece.
It's kind of fun.
It's sort of a fun game.
AUDIENCE: Why did you decide to,
for example in measure seven,
write a C flat instead
of the [INAUDIBLE]?
RAY: That's a very
good question.
I mean you might have to ask the
composer, Greg, who's not here.
But my guess would be, although
there's no key signature.
I mean I think of this
as in the key of G minor,
which has got flats.
So I think that's probably
what he would say.
Although again, not having a
key signature that probably
doesn't make a lot of sense.
I don't know.
What do you think?
FRIESEN: I think
you're right now.
RAY: But I think the idea
is that it's in a flat key,
and so C flat would be a little
bit more conventional, for lack
of a better word.
I'm sort of one of those
guys where I actually
prefer to see B natural if
I'm sight reading something.
AUDIENCE: There is
a B natural, right?
RAY: That's true that's true.
OK.
Well, now you've
completely stumped me.
FRIESEN: It could be
the software, too.
RAY: It could be the notation
software, which is oftentimes
when musicians make unusual
choices, it's not actually
a choice, if you
know what I mean.
HARVEY: Can I just
make another point.
I think it would be
interesting to ask
Greg about when he
comes by on Monday.
Because actually a lot of these
phrases in number one and two
seem to be almost three beat
phrases if you look at it.
RAY: That's true.
HARVEY: --it really
anticipates and it then it
goes into three, per se.
So it's an interesting
[INAUDIBLE]
with the kind of five
integral beats or whatever.
RAY: I would agree.
Yeah, you're right.
They're not typical
phrase lengths.
Yeah, you're right.
There's a lot of threes,
three beat phrases.
Anyway, the other thing I just
wanted to point out quickly
was just, like I said,
you see obviously,
if you're looking for
motives to grab onto.
Well, maybe you
can tell me what's
one thing you might
circle if you were going
to try to pick out things
that make this melody
unique or different
or interesting?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RAY: Right.
The little ascending thing
at the beginning, right?
You see that towards the end.
You see it actually
all over the place.
The second line.
And the third line.
Little ascending intervals.
That's a nice one.
How about the thing in section
two, the repeated note?
That comes back again and
again in section two, right?
And then the other
thing I would point out
would be maybe this sort
of quarter note triplet
thing, which comes in
once in the first section
and then comes in again
in the second section.
Again these are
all things you can
try to incorporate
into an improvisation.
So like I said,
this would be-- I
think will be an interesting
thing to work on.
And we'll get you guys playing
on this tune on Monday.
Cool.
So let's see.
Getting back in kind
of the diatonic thing.
I wanted to do that.
Get you guys playing
a little bit.
I guess I'll hand
out this thing.
So basically, I mean this
is something you probably
don't even need to look at, but
what we're going to try now,
get into a little
bit, is just G major.
And we're going to spend
some time in G major.
So I hope you like G major.
Conveniently a transposed
to A major for those of you
who don't read.
FRIESEN: Did you do the
transposition yourself?
RAY: I did the
transposition myself.
This was not done on a computer.
This was done by hand,
the old fashioned way,
with a needle and thread.
Anyway, like I said, I
don't even necessarily
why I'm handing
this out because I'm
sure you guys all know
what a G major scale is.
Well, Mark doesn't.
We'll get Mark clued in.
But I thought this might
be an interesting thing
to spend some time with.
And if we have time at the
end, maybe Eugene and I
will play another piece from our
repertoire, our vast repertoire
of duo songs.
But basically, like I
said, the whole idea
of doing improvisation in
a diatonic setting-- which
as you heard from the
first piece we played,
can really go as far
as you want it to go,
or it can stay kind of
small, is a really, I
think, an interesting
way to practice.
And I think it's a
really interesting way
to kind of develop a lot
of the improvisation skills
that you use in other kinds of
improvisation, including atonal
and jazz.
Like I said, any
kind of improvisation
you do, I think the
diatonic version of improv
is I think a good way to--
it's a good, as Eugene said,
limitation, a good way to
restrict the amount of things
you have to think about.
So it sounds like someone
is knocking on the door.
Let's do this.
I haven't really
necessarily planned this.
But I'm going to do this.
Eugene and I will do a little
bit of a G major improvisation.
The other thing I'll point out
on the bottom of this page,
again these are all
diatonic chords.
Chris, you're a
piano player, right?
Are there any other
piano players here today?
Cool.
So but for anybody who's
doing chordal instruments-- I
see the banjo and the guitar--
obviously, one of the things,
and of course Eugene
is as well versed
in playing chordal
accompaniments,
probably more so than
pretty much any other cello
player I've ever met.
It's one of his strengths.
Again it's something you'll
see more evidence of tonight
in the concert.
But you see I've just drawn
out some basic diatonic chords.
If we're in the key
of G major, these
are all just seventh chords.
And it's not necessary.
It doesn't mean you have
to play seventh chords.
But these are examples.
G major, A minor, B minor,
C major, D seven, E minor,
and then the minor
seven with a flat five
if you go to the seventh
degree, F sharp, right.
So these are all, in terms of
harmony, good source material.
It doesn't necessarily
mean that you
have to move them around a
lot or move around at all.
Of course, but it's
again, thinking back
to that first tune
we played, just
using a major scale
as a source material,
there are just so many
options in terms of harmony.
Sometimes like I said, those of
us who come from a jazz world,
we're used to things
moving more, moving quickly
and in a less diatonic fashion.
But again, like I said, just in
the diatonic areas, you know,
you've got 7 chords right here.
And then you've got
all these chords
with different kinds of roots.
You know you've got G major
with a third in the bottom.
You can do a C major with
the fifth on the bottom.
You can do again, like I
said, all of these things.
You've got a lot.
Even just in the diatonic realm,
you've got a lot of options
as chordal instruments.
So let's do a short little
improv in G. Can we do that?
And then we'll get you
guys to come in on this.
Actually and Alex,
you're a vocalist.
ALEX: Yeah, I'm doing vocals.
FRIESEN: You're doing vocals.
All right.
Cool.
So we'll get you all involved.
So actually let's do this.
We'll start.
At some point, I'll get you.
We'll swap places, Chris.
But for now, Eugene
and I will start.
And then maybe James,
we'll get you to come in.
At some point I'll
give you a nod,
and you can come in and join us.
And maybe one of
us will drop out,
or we might just keep going.
So we'll just do a little
bit of round robin,
bring you guys in,
brings guys out.
We need your note cards, Mark.
You guys have all seen the
Aardvark Big Band, right?
Do you still use the note cards?
I always love that system.
Mark's got the system of
like, to cue the entire band,
he holds up a card that
says letter E. It's great.
HARVEY: Our festival jazz band
direct, he's now swiped that.
RAY: Oh, he swiped it from you.
HARVEY: Big concert on
Saturday, and everyone
was using his own card.
Imitation is the
sincerest form of--
[LAUGHING]
FRIESEN: The sincerest
form of theft.
RAY: All right.
So like I said, I haven't
really planned this.
So we'll see where this goes.
Why don't you start?
[PLAYING MUSIC]
RAY: James.
Sorry I've forgotten
your name, next to James.
AUSTIN: Austin.
RAY: Austin.
How about some trumpet?
Want to put some oboe in there?
Uh oh.
Dry reed.
That's OK.
Adrian, can you come
in on some guitar?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You're Adrian.
Try some chords.
Try C major.
RAY: Can we get some flute?
Yeah.
And some banjo?
Nice.
Yeah.
Alex, want to try
some long tones?.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Try some oboe?
Yeah.
Nice.
Wanna try some flute, Adrian?
Yeah.
We'll get the whole thing going.
Chris, why don't you jump in?
Yeah.
Mhm.
Nice.
All right.
Beautiful.
That was great-- that was great.
Yeah.
It is-- it's hard to
jump out there, right?
I know, especially when
your reed's not wet.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
HARVEY: Then it's really hard.
But no, seriously though,
it's hard to put yourself out
there sometimes.
And again, I know
you guys have been
working with Tom on
some improvisation.
I imagine you've probably
been doing some group stuff.
There's always a little safety
in numbers kind of mindset,
which, I know, is totally cool.
But, you know, frankly, what's
nice is that I could tell you
guys were all listening.
You're kind of trying
to find the group,
find the place to go, find the
place to be, where you're not
where you're not
sticking out-- you're
contributing without
going too far.
Which is great,
listening is obviously
one of the biggest things.
You have anything you want
to try with these guys?
FRIESEN: Oh sure.
PROFESSOR: We have a whole
room full of musicians
who are versed in G major.
FRIESEN: Oh, I know.
That's so great.
I might just say that, in
terms of you are what you eat,
I've always been
intrigued with how
to practice to become
a better improviser.
I mean, at first I thought
improvising was just
a state of being.
It really was not anything
you can prepare for.
But that could not be
further from the truth.
You know, preparation
plays a huge part
in being a good improviser.
So sometimes I
think about using--
if you think of your brain in
two different parts, you know,
the left brain and
the right brain.
You think of that left
brain as being the rigor
part of your brain,
the part of your brain
that is curious about music.
Odd meters, scales, seventh
chords dominant chords,
chord substitutions, diminished
chords, diminished scales.
All these things
are exotic foods
that are just very
enjoyable for us musicians.
We get fascinated
with them, and we
want to spend time with them.
They're are like my kids
when I got them art supplies.
They would not only use the art
supplies as they were intended,
but of course, they wanted
to taste it, and put it
on the walls, and on their
clothes, and on your clothes.
It was everywhere.
They wanted it to be a full
body sensory experience.
It was something kind of
elemental as a major scale
and the modes of that scale.
Each of these modes
and each of these keys
are things that you may
understand with facility
at first glance,
and yet, there's
no way of predicting how
your understanding of them
will be enhanced by your
spending time with each one.
So for example, I
have a CD of drones.
It's just-- maybe
you have these,
too-- it's just a
root and a fifth
and a couple of different
octaves in all 12 keys,
and each track on the
CD is six minutes long.
So one day, I might say,
OK, today's Phrygian day.
And I'll go through, and
I'll just let the CD roll.
And I'll play six minutes
improvised in Phrygian mode
through all 12 keys in that day.
Just as an example of
how you can use drones,
as a very simple example.
But I think what I
wanted to say, mostly,
was that your curiosity and
your loving attention to each
of these musical elements
is something that goes deep
inside your being, inside
your inner musician.
And then these become
the tools that you
use, the colors that you
use, to really portray
your expressiveness, when
you're in a situation
that you can access
these things intuitively.
So one of the things
that I really love
is odd meters, for example.
I've been fascinated
with the odd meters.
And we haven't really
spoken about rhythm
that much, but really, the
success of this improv we just
did was really mostly
about this little motor
that we set up at
the beginning of it,
and varying it in so
many different ways
with syncopation, and
keeping it moving along.
And using the odd
numbers in rhythm,
I think there's a lot of power
and a lot of energy in there.
So we could think
about 3, for example.
Even 3/4 is such a
magical kind of place
to be in, because
with quarter notes,
with in each quarter note,
we have 12/16 in each bar.
And 12 is a great number.
It not only has all this
astrological significance,
but, of course, is
divisible by 2, 3, 4, and 6.
So for us musicians,
there's just
a whole storehouse of energy and
rhythmic tension and propulsion
available with that number 12.
So let's take 3/4,
and, first of all,
let's just play
some kind of pattern
that we are subdividing
with the quarter pulses.
Can you play along with me?
Anything you can come up with.
You can just play
16th notes, but really
feature those quarter pulses.
Can I hear all the 16th notes,
but just accent the quarters.
Keep going.
Nice.
That's beautiful.
Great.
Let's try another way now.
I'll keep this quarter
pulse, but now we're
going to come up with a pattern,
where we accent every three
notes.
So this is essentially,
we're going
to be playing four groups of
three notes in the same amount
of time as we were playing
three groups of four notes.
Do you follow?
So we were doing 1-2-3-4,
1-2-3-4 1-2-3-4, 1,
now we're going to do 1-2-3,
1-2-3, 1-2-3, 1-2-3, 1-2-3,
1-2-3.
So find a three note
pattern where you can really
feature the first note of each.
Go ahead.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 1.
I can tell you guys
feel it already.
That's really, really fun to do.
So let's see if we can a
little round, where we'll
start with the people doing
the quarter pulses, and after,
let's say, two bars,
the other group
will come in with
the quarter pulses,
while the first group
shifts to the three pulses.
OK.
And Chris, you can be on
this side-- up through,
let's see, one, two, three,
four, Ja-- up through Jacob,
and then the rest of you
are in the second team, OK.
We'll start with two bars of
3/4 doing the quarter pulses,
and then we're going
to evolve to the three
pulses, the dotted
eighth note pulses,
while they come in
the quarter pulse.
Clear?
One?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] not
clear-- so what's going on?
FRIESEN: After two
bars, you come in
with a quarter pulse figure.
AUDIENCE: And then
they'll switch?
FRIESEN: They'll switch
when you come in--
AUDIENCE: And we'll just stay--
FRIESEN: And you'll
switch after two bars.
You're going to go to the
dotted eighth note figure,
the three figure we just did.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRIESEN: We just cycle.
We'll just come back to what
we were doing before, OK?
1, 2, 3.
2, 2 switch.
Switch.
And switch.
OK, you got it?
Let's try a little duet, just
quickly, and see if we do it?
Does everyone feel
comfortable with this?
Let's try a flute and oboe duet.
And you don't have to
choose which roles you have,
and you don't have to switch.
But let's say the
first person who starts
will start with a quarter
note kind of feel.
And this is just about rhythm,
it's not so much about melody.
So see if you can just make this
kind of poly-rhythm evident.
We've got the 4 and the
3 going simultaneously.
So let's try a
flute and oboe duet.
It's going to be like a 45
second, or 49 second world
premiere.
That's it, yeah
guys, good for you.
What do you think?
Do you like it?
AUDIENCE: It feels
like a template.
I feel like if we--
FRIESEN: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --got
very used to this,
we could do lots of
innovative things
once this becomes second nature.
FRIESEN: Exactly right.
It's a template.
That's a great way
of looking at it.
Let's try another one of these.
Let's try a James
and trumpet duet.
I'm sorry to interrupt
already-- this
is totally cool-- you don't
have to play all the 16th notes.
You can play a resulting
rhythm that just plays down
a funky quarter note feel,
for example, you know I mean?
And feel free to switch.
In fact, let's make that a
little rule of this duet.
That at some point you're
going to switch roles.
OK?
Don't try to plan it out.
You'll just screw it up.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER].
FRIESEN: Good for you guys.
Yeah.
That's cool.
What I love about
it, too, and what
we haven't talked
all about-- and that
is how to make an
accompaniment, in a kind of pure
and very exposed
setting like this.
And you guys are really
good at that already.
I found you gravitating towards
that melody and accompaniment
role between you, which is
a great musical instinct.
I love how you did that.
RAY: And something that
a lot a horn players
don't think about
because you're thinking--
FRIESEN: So true
RAY: --about playing
melodies and leads.
FRIESEN: I know, I know.
I really notice it
because the cello
has this tradition
of accompanying.
The written repertoire
is really 90%
playing accompaniment roles.
So I really appreciate
it when I come
across a violinist
or a trumpet player
who is sensitive to that--
or a drummer-- who's really
a great accompanist,
really appreciate it.
Anyway, just as an example of
how a kind of musical element--
in this case, the four against
three-- with curiosity,
as you experiment with
this, you will gradually
find yourself wanting
to compose stuff.
You'll be improvising stuff that
you get attracted to and just
through being
drawn to something,
with your natural curiosity with
the musician's love for music.
You'll find yourself
wanting to expand it,
and with your
loving curiosity, it
will grow into something
that could either
be a composition, or just part
of your personal vocabulary,
for your personal comfort.
I think that's
kind of what we do,
is collect this quiver full
of musical arrows of all
kinds of different descriptions.
And rhythmically, it's just
a huge, huge great world.
So I envy you, that you've got
this long life ahead of you
to check all this stuff out.
I do, too.
I'm doing the same thing.
RAY: Indeed.
FRIESEN: Where
are, we time wise?
HARVEY: We have about
maybe five minutes more.
RAY: Yeah, cool.
I just wanted to mention
that Eugene, as I mentioned,
we both are teaching
at the Berklee College,
and if you ever get
a chance to hear--
and I don't know
if you guys wander
all the way across
the river to Boston,
there's another city
over there-- they've
got some cool things going on.
Anyway, no seriously,
if you ever
see a notification for a group
called the Berklee World String
Orchestra, it's led by Eugene.
It's a string orchestra,
as you might expect.
It's got all the string players,
many of the string players
to go to Berklee.
And one of the things that's
remarkable about this group,
besides the fact
that many of them
are actually really
good improvisers,
is that Eugene does
amazing work getting
them to play rhythmically-- and
getting them to play rhythms
in all kinds of different
styles of music, world music.
A lot of original stuff.
A lot of remarkable
repertoire that they do.
But like I said, a lot of
it is based on-- at least
my concept of what
Eugene does-- is based
on working with rhythms
with this ensemble.
And without a doubt
it's worth checking out,
if you get a chance to see that.
FRIESEN: One of the
ideas of the group
was to activate the great
world of rhythm, especially
from Africa, and South
America, and North America,
with jazz-- well,
all over the world--
without a rhythm section.
So all the rhythms
are really spread out
and written into the parts.
There's this great interlocking,
[INAUDIBLE] and all the parts
are rhythmic, and I
think pretty fun to play.
And that's the
experiment-- making
rhythmic use of
string instruments.
RAY: So we just have
a few minutes left.
Are there any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I was talking
to someone the other day
about perfect pitch.
There's this notion
that some people
have inborn perfect pitch.
And they are, from
birth, are annoyed
if something is a couple
cents sharper than they
remember it being.
Something like this.
I don't have anything
like that, but as I
listen to more and more
music, the different pitches
start to feel different.
And they have these distinct
sort of personalities.
And we haven't talked
about this much,
and I haven't heard people
in improvisation talk
about this at all.
But you use that kind of thing?
So you feel like the pitches
have different feelings, colors
to them that you can use?
The same thing, maybe
transposed up a couple steps
would feel different?
RAY: Yeah, that's an
interesting question, actually.
I do.
I feel like different
notes, different keys,
have different feelings to them.
I mean, I'm one of those
people that has perfect pitch.
I don't necessarily--
to get back
to what we were
saying originally--
I don't necessarily
know if the piano
is tuned at 442
versus 440-- maybe
there are people that
tuned in-- I'm not.
But I suspect most
people aren't.
But yeah, it's something,
and it's interesting,
too, the other thing I thinking
about as you were talking
was, from an
improvisational standpoint,
often people sometimes come
up to me, and they ask me,
do you have perfect pitch?
I say, well, yeah, I do.
And they go, oh, that must make
it so much easier to improvise.
Well, no, it's not that easy.
It's not that simple.
And I know, again, only
speaking from my own experience,
it does help in some
small ways, I suppose.
If, you know, Eugene and
I walk out on a stage,
and without talking about it,
he just starts bowing a note,
having perfect pitch will tell
me, oh he's started on A flat.
But once he starts playing,
and I start playing,
you don't think
about perfect pitch.
I'm not analyzing, oh,
his D is a little sharp.
And I don't know,
that's going to bug me.
No, no, no.
I'm not going to--
if I were to try
to be that analytical in the
moment, it would drive me nuts.
AUDIENCE: I was more
talking about aesthetics.
I was more talking about
what sort of a bearing
does the aesthetic of different
keys have on your feeling--
FRIESEN: Well, in my case,
my experience of music
is related to the cello because
I've had this thing in my lap
since I was 10 years old.
So when I hear a
note, I can kind of
imagine where it
is on the cello.
And that's the way that
I know what note it is,
but it's also the way I can
visualize what key a melody is
going to sound good
in, because of how
it will sound on the cello.
Yeah.
And then I think
an interesting way
to play with that is to
transpose as much as you
possibly can in all 12 keys.
You know, start with a
simple melody, and just
the head of a tune, or an
eight bar phrase, or 16 bars,
and try playing it all 12 keys.
And take your time.
If you're like I am,
it'll take a long time
to get through 12 keys at first.
But eventually, you begin to
open to how the intervals work,
and hear how your instrument
sounds in all those 12 keys.
And that's another way
to sensitize yourself
about how you react emotionally
to what key something is in.
It's very personal,
but it's very real.
That was a good question.
RAY: It is, yeah.
And I think, just
one short comment,
because we talk about
with improvisation, we
talk about feelings and being
in touch with how things feel,
and how things sound.
And I think the key
that something's
in is one of those things.
One of those things that
gives you information.
If I sit down and
play a B minor chord,
that's going to give me
a certain feeling that
would be a little bit
different if I played
an A minor chord
or a B major chord.
So that all kind of gets
mixed in, for me at least,
the key something is.
I think it does.
It gets mixed into how I how I
approach it as an improviser.
And which is why what Eugene
says a great idea, you know,
you learn to tune,
and you say, OK,
cool, I'm feeling really good
about playing blues in F.
And now try blues in D flat.
It's going to feel
really different.
Partly because you probably
don't play in D flat as well
you do in F, but partly
just because it's
going to sound different.
So I hope that answers
your question a little bit.
Any other-- Yeah.
Adrian?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have any other
useful exercises sort
of like [INAUDIBLE] practice
certain improvision skills.
RAY: Excercises for
practicing improvisation?
AUDIENCE: Just like for
practicing songs [INAUDIBLE].
RAY: Right, yeah
there's so many.
FRIESEN: There's some
great technology, too,
you guys have probably
checked out, right.
I mean, everything
from a looper pedal,
so you can make your own
loop, and practice along
with it to Band in a Box.
And iReal b, the
iPhone app, where
you can play tune, in
any key, in any tempo.
Those are all great things.
I think it should be driven--
in my personal opinion--
it should be driven by your
curiosity for what you really
love.
You know, any time it becomes
an intellectual exercise,
it's something to be aware of.
I would counsel to gravitate
towards things that you're
really, truly drawn
to that gives you
an emotional response.
We talked about the
one side of the brain,
the rigor side of the
brain, and the other,
I sometimes refer to as the
surrender part of the brain.
In other words,
when I improvise,
I often place myself in
this kind of more open mode.
It's where the
music just is there,
and I'm contributing
to the music
without having to
analyze it, or try
to remember anything
I practiced.
It's really just a way of
being with your imagination
and with your more
open, emotional state
inside the music.
That's something that's
hard to practice in school.
So that's why it's so
important to find a place
to practice that you're
comfortable in, that hopefully
sounds good for your instrument,
and spend some time there,
just making the connection
between how you're feeling
and how it sounds.
How comfortable you
are and what you love.
RAY: Yeah, I think that's great.
I think that's great advice.
I mean, just again
piggybacking a little bit
on what Eugene was saying,
oftentimes, you'll find things.
You'll find things that excite
you when you're listening.
You'll hear something at a
concert or on a recording,
and you'll go, wow that's great.
And I think this
is how most of us
do it, and have done
it, for our lives.
For me, I would be in college,
sitting in a class and Mark
Harvey, or whoever
my teacher was,
would put on a recording
of, you know, Bill Evans.
And I'm like, wow, I've
never heard this before.
I've never heard someone play
the piano like that before.
And then it's like, OK, now I
got to go check out Bill Evans.
And now, after having
done that, my playing
has little bit of
that in it, right?
Because he's one of
my favorite pianists.
I think that's sort of
what Eugene is saying.
Stuff that you're drawn to,
explore it, jump into it.
It can be anything
and everything,
but then once you
start exploring it,
then you'll find resources.
You'll find transcriptions
of Bill Evans solos,
and, of course,
recordings, which
are very easy to get,
mostly, nowadays.
And like I said, there's
a lot of good resources
out there for working
on improvisation.
But just find things that you're
drawn to, even if it's just
six measures of a
John Coltrane solo.
It's like, I love
those six measures.
I got to learn
I got to get them--
I got to have them.
And you learn them, and
you start playing on them,
or it could be anything.
FRIESEN: The stranger
your interests,
the more interesting of a
player you'll end up being.
RAY: It's true.
So, cool.
FRIESEN: You are what you eat.
Watch your diet.
RAY: Watch your diet.
So.
HARVEY: Wise words
on which to end.
Let's give him hand.
FRIESEN: Nice to hang
out with you guys.